thank you alejandro yes we are here with
one of the young stars of american chess
jeffrey sean after a very smooth victory
jeffrey tell us a little bit how does it
feel to be back over the board here in
saint louis
yeah um i guess it's been a while um
especially for me personally uh my last
event was the uh grand swiss and riga
back in november so
yeah it's been a while just good to be
back really enjoying the weather so far
so yeah
tell us a little bit about this game it
felt like your typical victory you just
got a nice advantage out of the opening
with a crafty idea in this uh scottish
game tell us a little bit about that
yeah actually i wasn't sure um
how i how i handled this so uh let's i
guess we can uh i'll just go back okay
yeah so okay yeah you can keep going
here
he was spending a lot of time were you
surprised by that
um a bit okay i saw that he had a couple
of boots games in this line but yeah i
mean i was a little bit surprised i
guess yeah
where do you think his real mistake came
so yeah i think
by the way i was wondering actually if
he takes on f3 first maybe this is a
better version like takes in bishop d4
were you out of your opening preparation
at this point
i had some ideas but maybe not in this
exact position so
yeah okay bishop
uh the point is yeah if i long castle
[ __ ] b5 i think maybe this is what
he wanted to get in the game right let's
point out why you cannot greedily yeah
here okay this is actually probably
playable but knight d5 maybe it's right
the idea you hang the knight but
remember that this bishop is now
targeting g7 and that would trap a full
rook not just
an exchange
so
well probably right i don't think the
bishop gets trapped
complicated
so black would play here
oh probably you have to take right you
have to take on d5 bishop takes g7 could
play f6 but that's pretty ugly all right
f6
yeah definitely not crystal clear but um
probably is the rook cannot go to g1
yeah this is a big issue how's there
it's mentally readying myself to put
something on the g7 square but
you can't actually access the g1 rook
takes d5 let's try to open up that
diagonal and get with the rook to h5
messy i need to help that bishop somehow
it is definitely messy but at the end of
the day on the worst case scenario
white will have two pawns
on the rook for two minor pieces no way
he's worse
yeah
so bishop d4 was played immediately
without the queen exchange and it did
feel that this end game was just very
unpleasant
for the black side and white's position
more or less float
yeah yeah i i think so but at some point
i feel like um
i made a slight inaccuracy so if we uh
continue on so yeah this
i think yeah 97 caught me by surprise
because i was expecting let's say castle
and then my idea was bishop d3
say bishop d7 seems normal and now i
want this bishop a3 to threaten knight
e2
and the bishop is kind of awkward
but he's surprised with knight d7
and i think i should now i should just
play keen c1 because he he freed up the
d5 square for my knight
so
i think kingsman would have been uh
simply better
but now bishop iii i don't like this
because now he okay i forced him to take
on c3
but here he made a mistake so i think if
he just castles it's not so bad for him
all right maybe even a solid move like
f6 i'm wondering
yeah f6 maybe maybe but i don't think
it's quite necessary maybe just castles
rook e8 and so on right
because yeah if i don't get the idea in
the game
and the idea of the game was knight e5
you played f4
knight
c6 and e5 and it just seems like
position is blowing up without any real
development from black
yeah i was expecting um so yeah knight
d4 king b2 i thought he was going to try
bishop e6
that he can he can meet see-through with
uh knight takes b3
yeah and this is yeah okay yeah he's
probably
doing well here
probably just to draw right
well actually he will move the rook
somewhere else yeah and then somewhere
else
actually even though that's not over
it's not so clear yeah because you do
have bishop b5 check at the end ah okay
picks up the right yeah it wasn't really
what i wanted
and now probably king e7 and followed by
rook b8 and you can resign so bishop e6
but yeah i think
the key idea here after bishop b6 is
king c1
so preparing um c3 again this is very
crafty right you realize this one here
here yeah yeah it's a funny uh yeah
diamond kind of
but yeah now if he goes keen seven i
guess i taken bishop b2 so
it still
should be good for me
the bishops are roaring in this position
especially this dark squared one
difficult to defend the diagonal
yeah this looks bad for black
but actually in the game he was he found
a good way to fight on because at first
i thought it's
close to winning but
so yeah let's continue here um he played
k7 instead
and then yeah maybe i had something more
precise but i went for c3 now 96
f5 knight f8 so actually
it looks really bad but
i wasn't sure how how to uh
to break this right so you went rookie
one
king d8 rook d1 repeated once but after
bishop d3
this look
to our eyes without any engines pretty
clear it it's definitely better but yeah
in this position i think
uh
yeah after g4 i was more worried about
rook b6 first defending the weakness
here on d6
and then like h4h6
and it's going to be
it's a better version of the game where
he allowed
tactics so
here i think it's not so easy for me and
we do have a result that one is over
between muradiabadi and uh raja muradi
abadi managed to secure the victory they
were talking about that those pawns on
the queen side will show the end of the
game in a little bit but let's finish
this one up 95 did surprise you and
let's just show the tactic in the game
bishop takes c5 a distraction here uh
for black of course it's kind of nice
that knight takes d3 inter mezzo doesn't
quite work we have this move rogue d6 at
the end and the king is caught it's not
quite checkmate but it is pretty bad as
you have to play bishop e6 losing the
piece for free
yeah i wanted to put out one more funny
idea that i saw so uh after h4
he can also try to take on d3 and rogue
b6
um and then i thought rook d5
threatening mate h6
and now i can still go c4 probably
and if okay bishop b7 i can move my king
for example and still the movement it's
funny how this king is getting mated
from every angle yeah this is actually
pretty sad for black and the position in
the game equally sad
uh this just isn't lost again we're
pointing out the weaknesses on the queen
signal real development to help them out
a very clean victory jeffrey thanks
congratulations uh jeffrey and uh well
hopefully we're going to see you again
here in the studio in the next few years
i hope so as well
all right let's